escribe este número con letra y no estoy
diciendo el número porque si no les doy
la respuesta así es que tenemos aquí
este número y lo vamos a reescribir lo
voy a poner con distintos colores para
que sea mucho más sencillo
punto decimal
del lado izquierdo del punto decimal
tenemos este número que ya no resulta
bastante digamos común ya es muy
sencillo para nosotros y nosotros
podemos saber que este 6 representa seis
decenas está en el valor posicional de
las decenas así es que tendremos seis
decenas lo que es igual a 60
tenemos un 3 en las unidades lo que nos
implica 63
y todo aquello que tenemos hacia la
izquierda del punto decimal lo
llamaremos enteros
63 enteros con ello después entraremos
en la parte de los decimales vamos a
hacer un poco de espacio para que quepa
toda la información
63 enteros tenemos a la derecha del
punto decimal las décimas en este caso
tenemos un 1 multiplicando una décima
así es que lo pondremos con el mismo
color
una
10a
vamos a cerrar esta para que se vea
mejor una décima y este cinco se
encuentra en el valor posicional de los
centésimos o centésimas colocaremos con
el mismo color una décima y cinco
centésimas
literalmente está bien dicho estos 63
enteros una décima y cinco centésimas
sin embargo lo usamos de una manera
distinta de la forma que hablamos
normalmente usualmente decimos 15
centésimas 63 enteros 15 centésimas pero
de dónde viene vamos a escribirlo y les
enseñaré de dónde vienen estas 15
centésimas
copiaré esta parte que no se moverá
y la colocaré aquí
aquí viene lo interesante este uno está
en el lugar de las décimas lo que
representa
las décimas y este 5 se encuentra en el
valor posicional de las centésimas
habíamos dicho ya hace un momento en eso
estamos claros si nosotros hacemos la
suma de un décimo más cinco centésimos
podremos operar de la siguiente manera
para que nosotros podamos hacer esta
suma primero buscaremos el común
denominador entre estas dos fracciones
que en este caso nuestro mínimo común
múltiplo es el 100 porque porque el 100
se puede dividir tanto entre 10 como
entre 100 pongamos entonces este
undécimo en términos de centésimos para
que nosotros veamos este décimo en
términos de centésimos lo
multiplicaremos por 10 tanto el
numerador como el denominador así es que
1 por 10 es igual a 10
10 x 10 es igual a 100 y ahora si
tenemos 10 centésimos + 5 centésimos es
igual a 15 centésimos
y entonces podemos decir que tenemos 63
enteros con
centésimos
que ahora sabemos que viene de esta
operación de sumar tanto los décimos
como los centésimos nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo